POI isolations they're one of the most
difficult tricks that we pick up in our
flow Journeys they can take us weeks
sometimes months sometimes even years to
get down but sometimes knowing why
they're difficult also tells us how to
make them easier to
learn Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I breaking down
for you three tips for making learning
isolations easier but before we dive in
I just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys pyrro Tera light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-b buus friend of the channel Becca
Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission all right so check it out this
is not a PO this is a hoop but as you
can see I can isolate the hoop just as I
can the PO and I would argue that it's
actually maybe a little bit easier to
isolate the hoop than it is the poy why
is that that question actually came up
in a recent lesson that I had with one
of my private lesson students and
getting the answer to that question
wound up up opening an entire can of
worms and giving me access to three tips
that I think are going to help you get
down your isolations see here's the
thing there are a bunch of ways that I
know that make learning isolations a lot
more difficult and that I try and steer
my students away from but then it dawned
on me if these things make learning
isolations more difficult then surely
doing the opposite of them makes it
easier to learn the isolations too then
right and so with that knowledge in mind
I'm going to show you three things that
depending upon how you want to interpret
them either will make your life harder
or easier when it comes to learning how
to do isolations so tip number one why
exactly is it easier to isolate a hoop
than it is a POI well this comes down to
the construction of the prop in general
see when we're isolating a hoop we're
moving it through a space that it's
uniquely suited for see the hoop is
evenly weighted in all different
directions that we're going to be
isolating the hoop in that means that
when it comes right down to it we just
have to shift back and forth between
letting it hang over our hand and
rolling it around under our hand like so
the hoop is already kind of helping us
out with its own Mass po however is a
different matter most sets of Po are
weighted such that they have more weight
on one end than they do on the other as
well as being larger on one end than
they are on the other this means that
when we go to perform isolations we're
kind of having to wrestle the mass of
the poy in some respects in order to get
the move down but there is a solution to
this problem now depending on who you
are and what you're spending preferences
are you may already be on top of this
one but if you can find sets of poi that
are evenly weighted that is the handles
and the heads are either the exact same
material or they're pretty similar and
thus have pretty similar shape
characteristics as well as weight
characteristics then guess what this
will give you a leg up on making those
isolations happen because now the PO is
evenly weighted across the dimension
that you're going to be doing the
isolations in a lot of people have found
over the years that if they evenly
weight their poy the isolation get a lot
simpler to do but it has to be said that
having evenly weighted PO is not a
solution for everybody I personally have
just never felt right with that kind of
weight distribution so there are other
options tip number two have you ever
tried to isolate a short po it's really
hard you're having to adjust constantly
and of course working inside of a circle
this size you're just having to keep the
POI spinning really really fast in order
to keep up when you lengthen the POI it
increases the size of the circle that
you're performing the isolation around
and that means that you get to take more
time in going through all those little
micro movements that keep the isolation
going so QED make your POI longer of
course lengthening the POI tethers is a
lot easier when you're working with such
of poy that are designed to let you
either swap them out or lengthen them
like say these emojo contact poy from
Lantern Smith when you find the right
length though you can just dial in
something that feels buttery smooth and
more importantly lets you slow down that
isolation to the point where you can see
every little movement that you need to
do as you're doing it but of course I am
going on and on and on about how the poy
are made the materials they're made out
of the weight the length Etc at a
certain point it has to come down to
just how you practice this stuff right
and yes yes in fact it does tip number
three you want to know the most
efficient way to learn all the pieces
that you're going to need in order to
get down those isol s it's to practice
your driving Styles first what exactly
is a driving style basically driving
styles are different ways that we can
arrange the momentum of the poy relative
to that of the hand we can just do big
pendulums if we want to put as little
momentum into the POI as possible we can
do extensions if we want to put slightly
more momentum into the POI and we can do
flowers if we want to add the highest
amount of momentum for the poy relative
to the hand I a big fan training people
to go back and forth between driving
Styles in order to learn how to add and
subtract energy from the poy on the fly
in particular I'm a big fan of a drill
wherein you start with a pendulum and
then you go around in an extension and
you do a pendulum and then you go around
in an inpin flower back to a pendulum
extension pendulum ins spin flow you
need to add and subtract momentum on the
fly in order to make this work which
guess what that's exactly what you need
to do when you're performing an
isolation too this is part of why I love
giving this exercise to beginners
because it's like a bite-sized version
of a drill that is going to help them in
the long run be able to add and subtract
that momentum in such a way that they're
going to be able to get to those
isolations much more easily so if you
want the inside scoop on how to get to
those isolations a lot quicker and a lot
easier practice those driving Styles as
soon as you possibly can and get adept
at subtracting and adding momentum on
the Fly it'll help you get here much
much sooner I promise cool I hope this
was helpful to youall out there uh
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
this video and of course to help my
channel grow and if you are looking to
improve your isolation skills you are in
luck because that is the theme of the
flow Circle for the month of November
the flow circle is a weekly exclusive
lesson that's available only to my
patreon supporters and the theme for the
month of November is isolations I'll
give you basic exercises to get those
isolations down as well as some
applications for where you can take
those isolations when you finally have
them in your muscle memory plus which
we'll talk about things like hybrids as
well as all kinds of cool things like
isolated weaves and the like too you can
sign up over at
patreon.com drexfactor poo the first
lesson is available now
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now you all rock thank you
so much and if you out there watching
enjoy this content that I make and you'd
like to see me make more of it the best
way to do that is to head on over and
support me at patreon over at
patreon.com Drax Factor poy and sign up
because there's a lot of awesome rewards
available there too so go check that out
support the Channel please and thank you
and if you would like to check out some
of my favorite isolation based poy
tricks I did a video of my top five
favorites that I'll go ahead and link to
down in the description as well as up on
screen thank you so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow yourselves
today and I'll see you with a new video
very very very soon take care now peace